Святковий настрій в німецькому Аахені цьогоріч дещо затьмарений.
Люди бояться можливої атомної катастрофи у сусідній Бельгії
Влада вже навіть роздає безкоштовні пігулки йоду.
Андреа Гаупт теж вже запаслася ними і завжди носить при собі.
Коли щодня натрапляєш у сумці на ці пігулки,
почуваєшся не дуже добре.
Одразу думаєш, що одного дня вони тобі можуть знадобитися.
Роздати йодові таблетки безкоштовно – таке в Німеччині вперше.
Але лише цього Аахену замало
влада міста вимагає у суді закриття бельгійської АЕС.
Ідеться про можливу аварію на реакторі,
і ми маємо зробити усе можливе, щоб запобігти катастрофі.
За сімдесят кілометрів від Аахена розташований
небезпечний реактор бельгійської АЕС "Тіанж".
Андреа не може збагнути, як бельгійці живуть поруч з ним.
Я не можу собі це уявити - жити тут.
Мені і так іноді страшно, коли розумію, що живу в Аахені,
незважаючи на те, що це трохи далі від реактора.
Але я думаю, що переїду звідси.
Встановлено, що в резервуарі реактора в Тіанжі є тріщини.
І вже багато разів енергоблок відключали через несправності.
У Бельгії також роздають пігулки йоду.
Однак бельгійське відомство з контролю атомної енергії вважає,
що Тіанж та інші енергоблоки безпечні.
Коли ми були непевні, чи безпечні ці реактори, ми зупинили їхню роботу.
Вони не працювали понад два роки,
допоки не довели, що вони безпечні.
Тепер вони можуть працювати надалі.
Є різні думки щодо цього.
У будь-якому випадку  наше завдання
всерйоз поставитися до можливих ризиків і бути готовими до них.
Мешканці Тіанжу вже сорок років живуть з атомною енергією.
Бельгія також вирішила відмовитися від атому
до дві тисячі двадцять п'ятого року.
Втім, дату можуть посунути, адже в країні
поки немає чіткої стратегії заміщення електроенергії.
Тиск з боку німців подобається не всім.
Якби німці більше займалися своїми проблемами, було би краще.
Думаю, бельгійці достатньо дорослі,
щоб самим подбати про свої справи.
Я схильна довіряти уряду Німеччини, країни, яка зрештою непогано функціонує.
Саме тому я радше вірю тому, що кажуть німці.
У мене ніколи тут не було страху, я не переймаюсь.
Але мене й не ображають вимоги німців.
Немає жодної причини для паніки.
Та німці іншої думки щодо цього і продовжують боротьбу.
Влітку Андреа допомогла організувати живий ланцюг від Аахена до реактора.
В акції взяли участь десятки тисяч людей з усієї прикордонної зони.
Противники атомної енергії вірять
їхні дії нехай і повільно, але змінюють настрої й у самій Бельгії.
Дедалі більше помітно, що бельгійці також проти реактора.
Спочатку бельгійські медіа були стриманими
і писали про це некритично.
Але згодом стали дуже навіть критичними щодо реактора в  Тіанжі.
Андреа та її однодумці і далі боротимуться,
допоки реактор в Бельгії остаточно не закриють.
Не важливо, скільки часу це займе.